you talked emotionally about interacting
with those families and that was what
life changing for you
uh penetrating I mean through my body
and soul all of us I'm indifferent
man now my wife's different
woman now my children
I believe are different children now
Matthew McConaughey profoundly impacted
by the devastating school shooting in
his hometown of Uvalde Texas the actor
opens up to Fox news's Special Report
host Brett Baier about the tragedy that
hit close to home and he describes in
detail his visit with the victims
families you see things you spend time
with people you have memories sometimes
you have to remember some things I have
some some some knowledge and was able to
receive some people's pain and anguish
and had some hugs that they were not
letting go now our hope is that we come
out of this especially for my children
can we come out of this valuing our own
life and value in life more than we did
before and appreciate the things that we
do have and the opportunities we have to
in our life and and to change things for
the better and Matthew called for change
earlier that day as he delivered an
impassioned speech in the White House
briefing room honoring the 19 Kids and
two adults who died when an 18 year old
gunman opened fire at Robb Elementary
due to the exceptionally large Exit
Wounds
of an AR-15 rifle
most of the body so mutilated
that only DNA tests
are green Converse
could identify them we need responsible
gun ownership responsible gun ownership
we need background checks
we need to raise the minimum age to
purchase an AR-15 rifle
to 21. many assumed this was bathy's way
of implying he intended to run for
political office which he's been open
about in the past politics seems to be a
broken business politics needs to
redefine its purpose and so as I move
forward in life and yes am I going to
consider leadership roles where I can be
most useful I'd love to I'm doing that
regardless he says not so fast I am not
running for political office
I'm here because on the 24th of May I
got the news that there was a mass
shooting in the town that I was born in
Uvalde Texas instead Matthew believes
he's here for a greater purpose I'm not
some other someone from in the
entertainment industry that decided to
swing by for an open cause this landed
on my I got the calling it happened in
the town I was born in all right so it
got very personal for me so I go in and
they ask and I tell them my personal
story and then after that though it's
time to get past or at least partial and
parlay my message past emotion and talk
about well now let's talk about what's
reasonable let's talk about what is
there something that we really can
change that's not emotional that can
help
foreign